quando a gente começou a dar aula de
música nas escolas públicas
chegou o diretor fez a seguinte pergunta
o que é que vocês fazem com essas
crianças
eles passam a nos ouvir na época não
soube responder aí que tava no começo e
o nome do programa que a gente está
trabalhando chamas prima programa de
inclusão através da música e das artes
o prêmio começou aqui na paraíba em
março de 2012 precisamente na fortaleza
de santa catarina lá em cabedelo um
pouco mais de 20 alunos e já nos
primeiros dias a gente fez questão diz
expandir para outras cidades
no ano seguinte em 2013 a gente já tava
em nove cidades em todo o estado da
paraíba de cabedelo a cajazeiras
os 20 alunos se transformaram hoje cerca
de 1.500 etapa conta essa turma toda
somos cerca de 100 professores o desafio
do prima é simples como todo grande
desafio criar a orquestra sem comunidade
de vulnerabilidade social
bom ano passado 2014
o primo conseguiu fazer contabilizados
123 concertos com um diferencial muito
simples
todos esses consensos aconteceram ou em
escolas públicas ou em hospitais ou em
asilos ou seja todos os concertos melhor
grande maioria aconteceu dentro das
comunidades onde os alunos estudam os
alunos vivem a proposta do prima não é
musicalizar as escolas
em princípio os concertos levam a crer
que é isso
porém nosso maior desafio
é levar cidadania a esses lugares e fica
muito vago falar de cidadania uma
palavra muito gasta
portanto gostaria de contar algumas
histórias que acontecem aconteceram e
certamente acontecerão é dentro desse
trabalho uma dessas histórias do
personagem chama-se velha é uma aluna
minha de falta muito muito muito muito
dedicada
seis meses mais ou menos de aula
ela chegou disse o professor eu não vou
mais poder vir pro prima e aí eu disse
mas o que aconteceu diz é a seguinte eu
moro só com minha mãe em casa meu pai
faleceu recentemente invadiram nossa
casa assaltaram e além disso a minha
escola está de greve não tem como ir lá
pra poder ter a carteira de estudante
paga meia passagem
edis bom nós vamos procurar resolver
esse problema
falamos com alex klein grande do primo a
gente explicou a situação e eles vão
disponibilizar a van que leva os
professores ainda tem vaga e assim a
gente faz até hoje não só zélia como
mais 78 alunos que moram há oito
quilômetros do pólo de ensino que é na
escola pública
quando foi na semana seguinte
zeca chegou assim muito sem jeito na
verdade sem olhar muito bem nos meus
olhos e diz o professor
então o negócio vale dizer que agora não
quero mais fazer parte do prêmio
eu estranhei aquela forma como ela
estava se comunicando e está vamos fazer
o seguinte vamos ter nossa aula e depois
a gente conversa sobre isso
assim fizemos só paramos sopram só
paramos ela colocou muita coisa pra fora
ali e depois eu disse e essa história
que você não pode mais eo prêmio
especial falar a verdade e se possível
não queria mas a verdade é que eu não
posso porque dessa vez não é o
transporte
mas aqui quando eu tinha 4 anos a minha
mãe precisou de ajuda para me criar
porque minha mãe passou de fora e uma
amiga dela veio ajudou durante vários
meses
só que hoje essa amiga da minha mãe
precisa também passar o dia fora e tem
dois filhos um de três e um de cinco
anos
ela pediu pra mim mas retribuiu o favor
com minha mãe continua passando de fora
para trabalhar na recarga caiu pra mim
ela tem 14 anos
ela me disse uma frase que eu nunca vou
esquecer
ela diz a seguinte forma ela fez pensou
eu confesso que se fosse só um
eu trazia pra cá e deixava amarrado mas
são dois e eu fiquei exausta
eu quero deixar essa história um pouco
aqui no cantinho e vou contar uma
segunda história de um aluno que pediu
pra não falar o nome dele módulo chamado
de joão joão começou até aula nos três
meses mais recente essa história eu
percebi que ele andava muito assim o
braço preso aqui
os tempos foram passando num determinado
de a inspetora que trabalha conosco nos
pólos de ensino ajudando a parte
burocrática desse professor eu acho que
tem alguns alunos que estão tomando
remédio sem receita médica então eu
fiquei preocupado a primeira coisa que
já mentiu pensa em chamar os pais
eu pensei bom depois mais pra frente de
seu chamar os pais
eu vou perder a oportunidade de criar
uma relação de confiança com os alunos
então eu chamei eles disse que história
é essa que está aí estou tomando remédio
e joão especificamente desse professor o
seguinte às vezes dá vontade de me auto
destruir porque as pessoas não me
aceitam começou como assim
eu sou gay está e por que você faz isso
é a minha forma de expressar e tal e
enquanto conversava com ele eu percebi
especialmente por um detalhe violence
toca assim então eu percebi que no pulso
dele tem alguns arranhões cicatrizes nos
dois
eu percebi que ele estava querendo se
expressar e é por isso que eu me corta
também é cega
joão tem 13 anos e está vamos fazer um
trato aqui você tem um violino em mãos
você quer se expressar
então a gente vai substituir a londrina
pelo violento
ele ficou me olhando assim está bom
na semana seguinte outra denúncia os
alunos dessa vez estava bebendo os mesmo
e aí eu disse bom nosso acordo é foi
descumprido então de fato pra vocês
continuarem trabalhando aqui estudando é
ensaiando só com a presença dos pais
responsáveis e aí joão trouxe na semana
seguinte a tia porque ele tinha me dito
que morava com a tia avó porque os pais
não aceitavam ele em casa o pai ea mãe
são separados a mãe pesar de ser
homossexual não aceitava a orientação do
filho o pai estava com problemas sérios
em drogas e atuava de forma muito
violenta contra ele e levou a tia elevou
de forma muito exaltada lá na conversa
ele é
já contei pra ela que estava bebendo que
estava tomando remédio e tal e agora eu
quero saber aqui pra que essa conversa
agente john a gente gostaria que você
contasse porque você estava fazendo isso
ele diz é porque eu às vezes dá vontade
de mel destruir mesmo tal as pessoas não
me aceita em casa e eu percebi que
estava querendo novamente dizer que eles
já têm nos dê mas ainda não tem data em
casa
ele está porque você não fala aqui então
passou a ter sabe o que é
olhou para ela sem cara muito
desafiadora é que eu sou bissexual e
ficou olhando pra ela um cara sem muito
desafiadora e ela com toda a ternura do
mundo
joão você vive comigo e com minha mãe no
caso a volta dele exatamente porque a
gente ama do jeito que você isso pra ele
foi sim certa forma inesperada e ele foi
abrandando foi muito singelo riso que
lhe deu ea quantidade de brilho no olho
que ele tinha e eu aproveitei aquele
momento ele está é aquele nosso trato
feito
eu não sabia o que acontecer depois
esperar só que ele está feito mas é
nessa hora que ele parou estava sentado
levantou a barra da calça e tirou de
dentro da minha gillette que ele se
cortava entregou assim a tia meu deus
obrigado a isso eu disse 'não calma
o acordo que a gente fez e tal ele com a
mão estendida entregando direta de sol
eu não quero isso não sabe que você tem
que fazer com isso aí sem que a gente
dissesse nada olhando se levantou foi lá
no lixo
jogou a gillette fora essas duas
histórias
elas dão a resposta que o diretor me fez
a pergunta o que é que vocês fazem essas
crianças crianças e jovens passam a nos
ouvir a resposta é simples a gente ouve
um exemplo é no início quando zelaya
falou pela segunda vez que não podia
mais um problema
eu no alto da minha 'presunção achei que
ela tinha sucumbido às dificuldades que
a vida apresentava pra ela
graças a deus eu tive ali momento de
iluminação quando estávamos em nossa
aula eu já estava pensando no bom se
você não aguenta ou então a música é
assim mesmo é pra tá muito então só
pensando ea conversa que a gente teve
depois foi tão verdadeira
mas foi tão singelas simples e tão
íntima que me trouxe um momento de
perceber o que o prima já vem percebendo
há muito tempo de que o princípio de que
a música é um meio para que a gente
possa conseguir várias outras coisas que
a gente não consegue normalmente no dia
a dia
o fato de tantos ele é como joão poder
derrubar várias camadas de suas
personalizadas para poder finalmente
chegar ao verdadeiro lado da história
foi algo sublime
e eu não quero insistir na música eu
falei pra vocês o nome de alex klein
brasileiro durou 25 anos nos estados
unidos e passou a vida inteira estudando
um instrumento chamado boi estava oito
horas por dia
era muita coisa além de um grammy é um
dos poucos brasileiros até um erudito
porém a obsessão e estudar música lhe
trouxe uma doença chamada distonia focal
o cérebro humano comum
o músico não obedece ele teve que
aplicar na carreira de consertar isto e
hoje está resignado ficando
completamente sua vida através da música
em si nada
há pessoas que talvez jamais teria a
oportunidade e no fim das contas o que
eu gostaria de deixar humildemente aqui
pra todos
um convite muito simples para que todos
nós do fundo do coração possamos
conhecer outras realidades que dessa
forma a gente possa ampliar nossa
hum